willkommen zur heutigen Vorlesung wie
immer sie ahnen es schon kommt das
begriffsnetz dran was von Mal zu Mal
immer und komplexer wird wie immer
springe hier ein bisschen rum und
beschleunige die ganze Darstellung um
auf den neuen begriffspunkt zu kommen
den wir hier im Spiel haben der wird
unten rechts angezeigt werden da sein
und sollen das sind die neuen Begriffe
die wir jetzt hier
vorfinden und sie sehen die Begriffe die
stehen auf der Ebene der Normativität
sollen steht natürlich näher zu
Normativität als sein deswegen ist es
ein bisschen entfernt und natürlich
besteht dazwischen eine Spannung das
heißt wir können vom sollen nicht
unbedingt auf das sein gehen genauer
gesagt er vom sein nicht unbedingt auf
das soll und wenn sie noch genau
hinschauen sehen Sie dieses Seins
Verhältnis steht unter dem Namen
den haben Sie schon mal an in einem
anderen Kontext kennengelernt nämlich
als es um die Frage ging ob das
unmoralisch Handeln unserer Vernunft
widerspricht und David jung hatte gesagt
nein es widerspricht nicht unsere
Vernunft wenn wir unmoralisch handeln
ja man kann noch weiter springen jetzt
im begriffsnetz und hier noch den
naturalistischen Fehlschluss sich
anschauen er hat der ist auch
interessant und sie wissen natürlich
noch nicht genau was es damit auf sich
hat aber wir werden heute auf diesen
naturalistischen Fehlschluss zu sprechen
kommen so sieht's aus und wir haben hier
noch frei eine Seite frei und sie an ist
schon in diesem Bereich werden unsere
noch
bevorstehenden Vorlesungen und ihre
Begriffe eingeordnet werden also hier
wird zum Beispiel noch der Begriff der
Gerechtigkeit
einbezogen werden hier wird noch
der Selbsttäuschung ist ja schon drin
den werden wir uns auch noch genauer
anschauen also sehen hier gibt's doch
Platz genug für weitere Begriffe jetzt
möchte ich auf der Beziehung noch mal zu
sprechen kommen so sehr der gute Mann
aus und er hat wie ich schon gesagt
hatte die These vertreten das
unmoralisches Handel unserer Vernunft
nicht zu wieder läuft
ja man kann das auf das Erkenntnis und
Begründungsproblem moralischer
Normativität beziehen also wie können
wir moralischen Normativität erkennen
und wie wir können können wir sie
begründen und Jung sagt wir können Sie
erkennen oder begründen nicht mit Blick
auf die Vernunft die Vernunft kann uns
da bei diesen beiden Problemen nichts
helfen die Folien finden Sie übrigens
auf
Ilias zur heutigen Sitzung die Vernunft
kann uns auch nicht zu moralischem
Handel motivieren wir kommen noch meine
eigenen Sitzung auf moralische
Motivation mehr zu sprechen wir haben es
aber auch schon ausführlich gemacht
dieses Thema und jetzt kann ist die
Frage wie kann ich Normativität bzw das
sollen begründen also wie kann ich jetzt
Argument dafür finden dass ein Satz ein
beliebiger Satz dass der Geltung
beansprucht ne immer ist auch die Frage
was hat überhaupt Geltung sind es Dinge
sind es
das ist auch eine spannende Frage ja das
wäre sozusagen das ontologische Problem
das könnte man nämlich auch noch zum
begründungserkenntnis und
geltungsproblem hinzuziehen das
sogenannte ontologische Problem all die
Frage nach der Existenz was existiert
überhaupt so oder was ist überhaupt
dasjenige was gilt was das sollen
ausdrückt was für Kandidaten kommen
dafür in Frage ich würde vorschlagen
Sätze ja Sätze sind es oder vielleicht
sogar auch ja imperative aber das ist
gar nicht so einfach ja sind das Gebote
sind es imperative bekannt würde sagen
es sind imperative aber darüber kann man
auch noch treffen streiten und ich werde
diesen ontologischen Punkt auch noch
aufnehmen in die aktuelle Übersicht so
jetzt gibt's den bekannten sein sollen
viel Schluss haben Sie bestimmt schon
mal gehört das lohnt sich hier gut zu
lernen auch als mögliche Frage des Typs
Wissensfrage ja sein sollen zwischen es
geht jetzt hier um das Problem wie wir
vom Zeit von deskriptiven Dingen
natürlich fehlt hier ein 11 Fehlschluss
wie wir vom sein auf das Sonnen kommen
wie wir letztendlich auch irgendwie
Normativität begründen können und jetzt
gibt es ein ganz bekanntes Zitat von
David Hue das muss man eigentlich als
philosophiestudentin oder Student schon
mal irgendwann gehört haben und Sie
hören uns jetzt schon gleich in der
ersten
Vorlesung in jedem Moralsystem sagte
bisher vorkam habe ich immer bemerkt
dass der Verfasser eine Zeit lang in der
gewöhnlichen Betrachtungsweise vorgeht
dass da sein Gottes feststellt oder
Betrachtung über menschliche Dinge
bringt jetzt kommt plötzlich werde ich
damit überrascht dass mir anstatt der
üblichen Verbindungen von Worten mit ist
und ist nicht kein Satz mehr begegnet in
dem nicht ein sollte oder sollte nicht
sich Wende
dieser Wechsel vollzieht sich unmerklich
diese Wechsel diese Übergang diese
Wechsel von Science Wörtern seien sind
bis bis hin zu sollen aber dieser
Wechsel ist von größter Wichtigkeit dies
sollte oder sollte nicht drückt eine
neue Beziehung oder Behauptung aus muss
also notwendigerweise betrachtet
beachtet und erklärt werden gleichzeitig
muss ein Grund angegeben werden für
etwas das sonst ganz unbegreiflich
erscheint nämlich dafür wie diese neue
Beziehung zurückgewährt werden kann auf
andere die von ihr ganz verschieden sind
also seinen sollen sind zwei ganz
verschiedene Bereiche da die
Schriftsteller diese Vorsicht Weise sich
brauchen zu erlaube ich mir sie meinen
lesen und natürlich auch den
Studierenden der Philosophie zu
empfehlen ich bin überzeugt dass dieser
kleine Akt der Aufmerksamkeit also zu
unterscheiden zwischen sein sollen
Argumentation Zusammenhängen alle
gewöhnlichen moralsystemen umwerfen und
zeigen würde dass die Unterscheidung von
Last und Tugenden nicht in der bloßen
Beziehung der Gegenstände begründet ist
und nicht durch die Vernunft erkannt
wird wir müssen gar nicht dass sie jetzt
auf diesen unteren Teil achten wichtig
ist das was jetzt fett markiert ist
diese Übergang von Seitenzahlen den jung
hier problematisiert und wir werden
jetzt darüber kurz diskutieren
ja also wir haben darüber diskutiert wie
jetzt dieser Übergang zu verstehen ist
jung so kann man ihn lesen scheint nicht
den Übergang vom sein auf sollen
grundsätzlich zu bestreiten sondern
erfordert einfach dass ein Grund
angegeben wird dass man also seinen
normativen Prämissen explizit macht und
dann kann man darüber treffen weiter
diskutieren
jetzt bin ich ein Beispiel also wir
können nicht unmittelbar von
deskriptiven Prämissen auf normative
Sätze oder Konklusionen schließen dann
müssen sind Grundannahmen die wir haben
wir brauchen weitere Zusatz Prämissen um
diesen Schluss vom sein auf sollen zu
begründen um den gültig zu machen ja
also wenn ich da nur Prämissen sind also
Grundannahmen wenn ich sage das ist der
Fall das ist der Fall das ist der Fall
und daraus folgt dass das dass das so
sein sollte dann sagt jung da müssen wir
noch zwischen Prämissen einfügen und die
müssen natürlich normativ sein macht
normativ mindestens weil aus dem sein
kann ich eben nicht direkt aufsäumen
kommen aber ich muss zwischen Prämissen
einfügen und ich muss die explizit
machen diese zusatzbremsen müssen müssen
eben auch schwach normativ sein und
jetzt hat hier noch eine andere
berühmter Philosoph sie haben schon wenn
ich berühmte Philosoph sagt nämlich
bekannt sich auf David Hume direkt
bezogen und hat in anderen Worten Humes
Einsicht noch mal ganz anders
ausgedrückt und zwar mit Blick auf die
Natur es sagt das sollen drückt eine Art
von Notwendigkeit und Verknüpfung mit
Gründen aus die in der ganzen Natur
sonst nicht vorkommt dieses Zitat finden
sie ziemlich auf den Folien das habe ich
noch hinzugenommen der Verstand kann von
dieser von dieser Natur nur erkennen was
da ist oder gewesen ist oder sein wird
es ist unmöglich dass etwas darin anders
sein soll in der Natur als es in allen
diesen Zeitverhältnissen in der Tat ist
ja das sollen wenn man bloß den Lauf der
Natur vor Augen hat Evolution und so
weiter hat ganz und gar keine Bedeutung
wir können gar nicht fragen was in natur
geschehen soll so wenig als was
Eigenschaften ein Zirkel haben soll
sondern was darin geschieht oder welche
Eigenschaften der letzte hat ja das ist
jetzt dieses sein sollen Problem
angewendet auf die Natur und sogar auch
noch auf die Mathematik
hier bei der Mathematik bin ich mir gar
nicht so sicher
ob es vielleicht nicht auch
mathematische Normativität gibt da gibt
es natürlich auch Regeln logisch Regeln
Axiome die eine normative Geltung
beantworten bei der Mathematik bin ich
mir gar nicht so sicher aber in der
Natur wenn Sie eine X evolutionsbiologin
oder eine Evolutionsbiologen fragen ob
es in der Natur ein soll gibt ob sich
die Natur wohin entwickelt muss oder ob
sie Natur absolute Werte gibt wie
geschützt werden müssen dann werden Sie
wahrscheinlich hören nein sowas
interessiert uns nicht wir brauchen gar
nicht sowas wie ein Wert anzunehmen wir
brauchen nicht mehr sowas wie ein Ziel
oder Zweck in der Natur anzunehmen wir
kommen auch völlig ohne diese Begriffe
zu Recht wird die moderne
Naturwissenschaft wahrscheinlich sagen
also kann knüpfte ganz an sich um an und
bezieht das ganze auf die Natur wenn wir
die Evolution betrachten dann finden wir
da nur Zustände die sich deskriptiv
beschreiben lassen und zwar nach
Naturgesetzen und nach bestimmten
Prinzipien aber wir finden keinen
normativen geldungen wir finden keine
Gebote dass dieses Tier das tun muss
oder sollte oder das der Löwe die
Antilope nicht fressen sollte oder dass
er sie schnell töten sollte damit sie
nicht arg leidet solche Dinge finden wir
in der Natur nicht wir können solche
Gebote nicht aus natürlichen Kontexten
ableiten
ja und jetzt bringe ich hier ein
Beispiel wie sie zurecht gefordert haben
man muss immer ein Beispiel bringen also
ein Beispiel
sollen wir die nicht menschliche Natur
schützen Naturschutz ist ein Riesenthema
ich biete gerade ein Seminar an zum
Thema Ethik des anthropozäns da geht zum
Umweltschutz Klimawandel oben rechts
mache ich dann auf Youtube einen Link zu
der Playlist rein können sie sich manche
dieser Sendungen diese Aufzeichnung
nachschauen sondern Masterseminar also
schon ein bisschen anspruchsvoll also
wir können diese Frage stellen sollen
wir den durchschnittliche Natur schützen
und jetzt könnte man einen sein sollen
es Fehlschluss derart begehen dass man
sagt
Prämisse meine Voraussetzung das sein
deskriptive Prämisse die Natur ist
organisch verfasst bzw besitzt eine
Ordnung eine natürliche Ordnung
hat es interagieren der Arten des
Gleichgewicht des ökologische
Gleichgewicht die Artenvielfalt die der
harmonische die harmonische Koexistenz
von Lebensformen
Korallenriffe und so weiter und so fort
und jetzt könnte man sagen und daraus
folgt aus dieser Prämisse also sollen
wir die Natur schützen
weil die Natur so harmonisch gebildet
ist und eine Ordnung Besitzung organisch
ist alles hat zu sein Zweck Natur und
deswegen dürfen wir die Natur nicht
zerstören aus dieser Prämisse können wir
sagen schließen wir auf ein sonnen
sowas finden wir so häufig solche
Argumentation überhaupt auch in
politischen Kontexten muss man immer
kritisch sein
auch in moralischen Kontexten kommt das
sollen vielleicht etwas zu schnell ja
und da müssen wir als Philosophen
Philosophen bezeichnen müssen das werde
ich auch wieder normal echt aufpassen
also immer kritisch natürlich bei
solchen normativen Dingen immer noch
mehr verlangen und es kann ja richtig
sein dass die Natur schützen sollen ich
glaube nämlich auch wir sollen sie
schützen aber ich muss mir Argumente
geben als nur zu sagen sie ist organisch
und deswegen muss ich sie schützen also
wie könnte das jetzt aussehen
Prämisse eins desktive die Natur ist
organisch verfasst bzw besitzt eine
Ordnung das wäre die Prämisse und die
Konklusion haben gesehen also sollen wir
die Natur schützen und jetzt müssen wir
zwischen Glieder einfügen jetzt müssen
wir die Gründe geben von den Jungfrau
dass wir das ganze nachvollziehen können
und jetzt versuche ich mal hier in
diesen Zwischenraum hier weitere
Prämissen einzufügen und es müssen auch
eben normative Prämissen sein wenn auch
war damit wir dann
nach Jungs Forderung diesen Schluss so
ziehen können dass er verständlich wird
dass wir Gründe angeben können das habe
ich in meinem Seminar gemacht also das
wäre jetzt in meinem Seminar bei Ethik
des anthropozänzt ist wird sich daran
erinnern wir können zweite Prämisse
einfügen deskriptiv die Natur verfolgt
eigene Zwecke auch diese Rede ist
natürlich Aussicht der
Evolutionsbiologie und haltbar aber es
wird verständlich natürlich Wesen
verfolgen auch wenn die
Evolutionsbiologie nicht braucht
Prämisse 3 und jetzt wird schon einen
normativdeskriptive Prämisse einbezogen
eine Natur die Zwecke verfolgt setzt
wert das sagt der bekannte Umwelt und
Naturphilosoph Angst Jonas vielleicht
haben Sie schon mal von dem was gehört
der sagt da einer Natur die Zwecke
verfolgt setzt Werte
die Evolutionsbiologie würde sagen Werte
gibt es natürlich nicht selbst auf
rudimentärste Weise es gibt es nicht es
gibt in der Evolution nur Fortpflanzung
habe ich mir sagen lassen überleben und
Nahrung diese drei Dinge aber ob das ein
Wert hat darüber kann man streiten aber
die Evolutionsbiologie würde das nicht
interessieren jetzt kommen noch eine
normative Prämisse eine Welt mit Zwecken
ist besser als eine Welt ohne
das natürlich auch eine normativ schwach
normative Prämisse eine Welt in der
keine Zwecke Vorkommen in der etwas
existiert was aber keine Zwecke hat
keinen Streben hat das ist nicht so gut
eine Welt der das nicht der Fall ist wir
sollten auf jeden Fall eine Welt
vorziehen die Zwecke verfolgt gegenüber
einer Welt die keine oder weniger
und jetzt können wir darauf schließen an
die organische Natur ist
schutzbedürftig Konklusion also sollen
wir natürlich schützen warum weil eine
Welt mit Zwecken besser ist als eine
Welt ohne und wenn wir die Natur
zerstören zerstören wir die Zwecke der
Natur nämlich die harmonischen ja so
wird jetzt ein halber Schuh draus
argumentativ und Sie sehen es ist
deutlich leichter diesen Schluss
nachzuvollziehen ja weil wir hier
zwischen Schritte eingebaut haben die
natürlich auch irgendwie schwach
normativ sind ja also schwachen normativ
und bis besonders zentral sind 4 Jahre
und darüber kann man sich treffend
streiten ja das können wir auch jetzt
hier noch ein bisschen machen
wie sie diese Argumentation finden dazu
beende ich kurz die Aufzeichnung
ja wir haben darüber diskutiert wie
diese Übergang zu verstehen ist von
Prämisse 1 zu Konklusion aber wir haben
darüber diskutiert ob man statt sollen
müssen sprechen kann natürlich nur dann
wenn dieses müssen kein Zwang bedeutet
dass mir jemand die Pistole den hält und
sagt mir jetzt schützt aber die Natur
sondern nur wenn irgendwie eine Geltung
enthalten ist eine Pflicht die nicht
bloß aufmacht Verhältnisse
zurückzuführen ist ne macht Verhältnisse
sind nämlich Desktop ja aber natürlich
können auch macht Verhältnisse
gewisse Zwänge vielleicht sogar auch
gewisse Normen bewirken das ist dann
eine spannende soziologische politische
Frage ja wir gehen weiter und jetzt
möchte ich Ihnen natürlich auch einen
weiteren Philosophen vorstellen
sogenannten ge-uhr ein Denker des 20
Jahrhunderts frühen 20 Jahrhunderts wir
hatten gestern schon Wittgenstein gehört
Wittgenstein hat viel von nur profitiert
ja hat auch bei ihm auch viel viel
rezipiert von ihm dann englischer
Philosoph soll der gute Mann aus und hat
ein Werk verfasst mit dem Titel Prinzip
ja Ethiker also die ethischen Prinzipien
an Dehnung an die Prinzip ja
Mathematiker von Deutschland Russell ich
weiß nicht ob jetzt die etiker zuerst
war oder die Mathematiker ich glaube die
Mathematiker war zuerst da also es geht
um ethische Prinzipien und kurz gesagt
kann man sagen
die nur knüpft irgendwie an diese
Einsicht von David jung an auch wenn es
nicht genau dasselbe ist wir wollen
heute auf diesen Unterschied mehr
eingehen wir können den Begriff des
Guten beziehungsweise des Prädikat gut
nicht definieren das ist die die
Grundthese der dieser Begriff ist
undefinierbar weil er so reichhaltig ist
natürlich sehen Sie das ist genau
dieselbe Sache wie vom sein auf sollen
zu gehen ja wenn ich das sollen nur
desinfektiven Dingen beschreibe will
dann fasse ich das nicht ja das ist eine
andere ist faire das sollen das
normativen wenn wir glauben wenn wir
etwas glauben gut das Prädikat ist
normative Prädikat gut durch ist ihr
deskriptive Prädikat angenehm definieren
zu können unterliegen wie einen
naturalistischen Fehlschluss
naturalistik verlassen die Frage ist
verlässlich kann verschiedenes bedeuten
und manche problematisieren diese
Übersetzung als naturalistische
Fehlschluss weil es dann so sehr in
Richtung geht und es hier vielleicht gar
nicht direkt ein Fehlschluss ist aber
man kann nur es Argument auch so
verstehen dass sie ein Fehlschluss
begangen wird weil man nämlich die These
vertritt das man eben
gut definieren kann oder dass man wenn
man sagt etwas ist angenehm daraus folgt
dass es irgendwie gut ist oder andersrum
das sind natürlich auch
schlussverhältnisse
bringen jetzt ein paar zentrale Zitate
wo ich die wichtigsten Passagen fett
markiert habe wenn ich gefragt werde
sagt jetzt nur was ist gut so lautet
meine Antwort das Gut gut ist und damit
ist die Sache erledigt und wenn man mich
fragt wie ist gut zu definieren so ist
meine Antwort das ist nicht definiert
werden kann und mehr ist nicht darüber
zu sagen
aber so enttäusche diese Antworten
klingen würden wir sind von äußerste
Wichtigkeit des erinnert mich natürlich
sehr an das Zitat von David jung der
auch sagt äußerste Wichtigkeit dass man
auf diesen Unterschied hier achtet
natürlich eine analytische Methode und
da würden keine großen Welt Entwürfe
entwickelt hier keine großen Ideen
sondern hier wird sehr analytisch auf
Details geachtet auf Details Problem ja
gut ist nicht definierbar warum weil
definieren immer bedeuten würde das
sollen in sein aufzulösen das geht nicht
er sagt weiter ich will sagen dass gut
ein einfacher Begriff ist sowie Geld ein
einfacher Begriff ist dass man so wie
man unmöglich jemanden der es nicht
schon kennt erklären kann was gelb ist
diesen auch nicht erklären kann was gut
ist Definition von der Art wie ich sie
suchen Definition welche das wahre Wesen
des
durch ein Wort bezeichnen Gegenstandes
oder Begriffs beschreiben und ich bloß
angeben was das Wort gewöhnlich bedeutet
sind nur möglich wenn der fragliche
Gegenstand unterkommt Begriff komplex
ist
also das ist hier entscheidend es ist
ein einfacher Begriff und deswegen ist
auch nicht definierbar weil wenn immer
schon voraussetzen müssen diesen Begriff
also ein Grundbegriff von seinen
normativer Grundbegriff
gut ist also sagte weiter sofern wir
damit die Eigenschaft meint die mit
einem Dingen zu schreiben dass wir mit
gut bezeichnen im entscheidenden Wort
findet das Wortes keine Definition fähig
die entscheidende sind von Definition
ist derjenige nur noch eine Definition
feststellt welches die Teile sind die
unveränderlich ein bestimmtes Ganzes
bilden und in diesem Sinne war ja gut
ein einfacher Begriff ist ein basaler
Begriff diesem Sinne entzieht sich gut
jegliche Definition da ist einfach ist
und keine Teile es ist einer jener
zahllosen Gegenstände des Denkens die
selbst der Definition unfähig sind weil
sie die letzten Begriffe sind mit den
alles fast definierbar ist definiert
werden muss
also wir können gut deswegen nicht
definieren weil wir nur mit weil wir gut
immer schon brauchen um zu definieren
und definieren zu können deswegen kann
gut nicht definiert werden ist die
Bedingung der Möglichkeit von
definierbarkeit sozusagen könnte auch
sagen ein transzendentales Wort oder
transentaler Begriff ja ich möchte noch
ein Zitat bringen um das noch ein
bisschen klarer zu werden John Stewart
will das war ein utilitaristischer
Philosoph sonst würde hat sich auf so
naive und sorglose Weise des
naturalistischen Fehlschluss ist
natürlich
nicht besser hätte ausdenken können gut
zu behauptet er bedeutet begehrenswert
und man kann das begehrenswerte nur
herausfinden wenn man herauszufinden
sucht was wirklich begehrt wird
das ist jetzt ein Beispiel des
naturalistischen fehlschlusses gut zu
erklären mit begehrenswert oder
bringe noch ein letztes Zitat dazu dass
sie jetzt die genaue Begründung sehen er
sagt nun der Fehlschluss ist in diesem
Schritt so offenkundigt dass man sich
wundert wie mir übersehen konnte
tatsache ist das begehrenswert die Salbe
nicht begehbar begehbar able to be
Design bedeutet so wie sichtbar visible
to be singt bedeutet
begehrenswert meint einfach das was
begehrt werden sollte oder was begehrt
zu werden verdient so wie
abschäumungswürdig bedeutet nicht was
verabschiedet werden kann also was
sichtbar ist
sondern was verabschiedet werden sollte
und verdammenswert was verdammt zu
werden verdient
Mill hat als unter dem Deckmantel des
Wortes begierenswert eben den Begriff
eingeschmuggelt über den er sich
eigentlich völlig im klaren sein müsste
nämlich den des Guten begehrenswert
bedeutet in Wahrheit das was zu begieren
gut ist aber wenn so vielfältig ist es
nicht mehr sinnvoll zu sagen diese seien
nur an dem nachprüfbar was wirklich
begehrt wird das ist der naturalistische
Fehlschluss ja zu versuchen gut über
tatsächlich begehrt begehrt ist und das
ist natürlich naturalistisch zu
verstehen deskriptiv zu bestimmen
begehrt was das was begehrt wird ist
immer schon gut muss immer schon gut
sein für ein Wesen das heißt darüber
können wir nicht gut bestimmen weil wir
im gehrenswerten immer schon den Begriff
des Gutes auf die ein oder andere Weise
voraussetzen begehrt wird nur das was
gut ist für ein Wesen also es ist
irgendwie eine Art von Zirkel Schluss
könnte man sagen oder Tautologie
von einem anderen Kontext ja darüber
müssen wir natürlich jetzt auch wieder
diskutieren weil die Sache nicht so ganz
unproblematisch ist
ja wir haben gesehen der naturalistische
Fehlschluss der wird immer wieder
begangen und auch in politischen
Kontexten wurde er wird er immer noch
begangen wenn man von der Natur von der
Verfasstheit der angeblichen Natur drauf
fließt wie man politisch irgendwas tun
sollte ja die Natur ist so in der Natur
ist das so rechte Stärken also sollten
wir auch so und so handeln und das ist
natürlich ein hochproblematischer
Schluss die in der Vergangenheit viele
schlimme Taten ermöglicht hat und immer
noch ermöglicht und jetzt geben wir hier
ein Ausblick auf die nächste Vorlesung
die natürlich dann im nächsten Jahr ist
stattfinden wird und da habe ich auf
Anregung einige Kommilitonen
Kommilitonen hier wie gesagt jetzt gehen
wir mal auf das Thema Gerechtigkeit
denken Sie immer dran alle Themen die
wir behandeln sollten immer unter der
doppelperspektive von individueller und
kollektive Person betrachtet werden ob
es kollektive Person gibt kann man
bestreiten
sage ich es allgemeine alle Probleme
alle Themen alle Begriffe die können
individualistisch betrachtet werden oder
kollektivistisch also im Kollektiv in
der Gesellschaft und jetzt spielt hier
bei dieser Frage was ist politische
Gerechtigkeit natürlich das Kollektiv
eine große Rolle hier geht es jetzt um
in der subjektive Verbünde von
verschiedenen Personen vielleicht auch
von nicht menschlichen Tieren die
sensibel sind für Ungerechtigkeit wir
müssen uns natürlich dann auch mit dem
Begriff der Ungerechtigkeit befassen sie
sehen unsere begriffsnetz wird immer
weiter
befüllt und weiter
vernetzt mit anderen zentralen Begriffen
Gerechtigkeit Ungerechtigkeit was ist
Gerechtigkeit das ist eine ganz
spannende Frage die Frage was macht
unser Handeln gerecht und natürlich
immer auch was macht unser Handeln
ungerecht das müssen wir uns natürlich
fragen und wir sehen das schon ein
Beispiel von
Tieren dass die natürlich auch irgendwie
schon so ein rudimentären Begriff von
Gerechtigkeit voraussetzen natürlich
nicht begründet wie bei uns wie können
wir Gerechtigkeit begründen diese ganzen
Fragen die sich auch für die
Normativität stellen vor allem für die
moralischen die stellt sich natürlich
auch für die Gerechtigkeit wenn auch
nicht in so starke Nase also das
Begründungsproblem wie können wir
Gerechtigkeit begründen das
Erkenntnisproblem wie können wir
erkennen was gerecht ist und was
ungerecht ist und das geltungsproblem
für wen gilt der Gedanke der
Gerechtigkeit wobei den finde ich jetzt
nicht ganz so wichtig wie die beiden
anderen Fragen oder Probleme natürlich
auch die ontologische Frage was ist
eigentlich gerecht ne also was ist
gerecht ist handeln kann Handeln ein
Fall von Gerechtigkeit sein können
soziale Normen gerecht sein können
Grundprinzipien gerecht sein Maximen
also das ist auch eine spannende Frage
die wir noch behandeln müssen
jetzt mein Lieblingsthema dazu habe ich
gerade ein Aufsatz akzeptiert bekommen
über Neid und Gerechtigkeit wir haben
kurz darüber gesprochen über das Problem
des Neides ich glaube wir können den
Neid so nutzen um von ihm ausgehen das
Problem wir Gerechtigkeit aufzuziehen
ich glaube der Neid erschließt uns die
Gerechtigkeit und zwar nicht deswegen
weil Leute wenn sie neidisch sind
ungerecht behandelt worden sind sondern
weil sie glauben ungerecht behandelt
worden zu sein da spielt natürlich auch
wieder selbst Täuschung eine Rolle auf
die wir dann auch noch eingehen im
nächsten Jahr aber die Frage möchte ich
auch behandelt und zwar deswegen weil
man ihm Neid Gefühle oder den Leid
Einstellung schon Appelle an
Gerechtigkeit Normen
erkennen kann wir erkennen es zum
Beispiel Futterneid und man spricht
manchmal von Futterneid wenn Tiere
Objektiv bevorzugt werden einander also
zwei Tiere befinden sich nicht
menschliche Tiere natürlich im Käfig ein
Tier bekommt mehr als das andere da
können wir dann uns mal Videos anschauen
von Studien wo dann das andere Tier fast
schon beleidigt zu reagieren scheint ob
das jetzt wirklich beleidigt ist oder
nur anthropomorphistisch ist als ob wir
nur menschliche Eigenschaften hinein
projizieren ist eine andere Frage aber
es hat man wohl festgestellt dass Tiere
Kooperation einschränken wenn Sie den
Eindruck haben ungerecht behandelt
worden zu sein Vergleich zu einem
anderen Wesen dass sie beobachten können
also wir wollen die Frage stellen wie
sich Neid und Gerechtigkeit zueinander
verhalten auch hier mache ich eine kurze
Diskussionsrunde um diese Probleme mal
ein bisschen anzudenken
ja wir werden in dieser Sitzung auch
noch oft schon rolls eingehen schon
rollt ist eine der wichtigsten
politischen Philosophen des 20
Jahrhunderts hat ein Werk geschrieben
mit dem Titel theory of Justice eine
Theorie der Gerechtigkeit ohne in diesem
Werk hatte vor allem das
vertragsschließend vertragssysteme als
Struktur der Gerechtigkeit ausgewiesen
und wir wollen darauf auch eingehen
zugleich hat schon rolls auch auf das
Gefühl oder die Einstellung des
resentment des übel wollen das
Gefühls ungerecht behandelt worden sein
hingewiesen und das werden wir auch
ausführlich diskutieren ja dann wünsche
ich allen Zuschauern zu schauen aber
natürlich den hier Anwesenden es geht
gleich noch weiter vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit und schöne Feiertage